claro y el problema era que los
demócratas tenían 50 tienen 50 sillas
los republicanos también tienen 50
sillas y no se habían podido poner de
acuerdo sobre quién iba a liderar la
cámara alta pero a partir de ahora
entonces serás ok summer el líder de la
mayoría en el senado mitch mcconnell
será el líder de la minoría republicana
en la cámara alta a partir de ahora
entonces también senadores demócratas
que se definirán en los próximos días
serán los encargados de presidir los
principales comités de la cámara alta-
ellos estarán entonces encargados de
poner los horarios los temas escoger los
testigos que a wang xin en los proyectos
legislativos de la cámara alta y pues se
conocerá entonces en los próximos días
los nombres específicos de estos
demócratas que liberarán la cámara alta
y también llegan noticias desde la
cámara baja estadounidense los
demócratas quieren votar el jueves para
expulsar a la republicana del estado de
georgia mayor y taylor greene de los
comités de la casa de representantes
porque es tan polémica esta congresista
claro y es que los republicanos además
habían dicho que prefería el castigarla
y no que se llevara a cabo la votación
mañana que la prohíbe entonces a la
congresista
marjorie taylor greene que es de georgia
acaba de empezar sus periodos
legislativos de dos años en la cámara de
representantes de participar en los
comités de educación de trabajo y de
presupuesto es todo este castigo que le
quieren hacer mayor interior green viene
después de que entre otras cosas pues
hiciera comentarios que apoyan la
violencia en contra de colegas como la
presidenta de la cámara representante
nancy pelosi y como alexandra ocasio
corteza además ella ha apoyado también
actos de violencia en el capitolio del
pasado 6 de enero además ha dicho cosas
como por ejemplo que el racismo no
existe en eeuu y que los tiroteos en las
escuelas de sandy hook y de parker
fueron una farsa
así que resultaba muy contradictorio que
ella que desconoce estos tiroteos en las
escuelas de eeuu fuera entonces pues
miembro del comité de educación por eso
para que no haga parte de estos comités
pues muchísimas gracias es cristóbal
vázquez desde la capital de eeuu
estaremos pendientes de la decisión
entonces sobre mayor edwin mañana jueves